لا شك ان الاستثمار في مقتبل العمر امر
مهم للغايه حيث يمكن الشباب من الاستعداد
للمستقبل بشكل افضل والحمايه من الضياع
للمدخرات الماليه وايضا بدايه طريق طويل
في عالم المال والاعمال هي احد اكثر
الغايات المهمه
بالاستثمار في سن العشرينيات بحسب تقرير
لخبراء نشرته منصات
اذا علم الاستثمار على واسع يمكن دخوله
وفق الخبراء بمال قليل مع خطط مهمه
للطوارئ والادخار المستمر مع البدايه لابد
من سماع نصائح الخبراء لاجل ضمان عمليه
استثماريه مميزه وناجحه دون السقوط في
الاخطاء
[موسيقى]
الينا في الاستوديو الباحث ومدير التسويق
نذير نينوح اهلا بك سعداء بلقائك حياك
الله صباح النور صباح الورد
بالفعل واحد في مقتبل العمر بالعشرينات من
الممكن انه يكون ويضمن مستقبلا خلال
السنوات القادمه حتى يصل الى عمري
وبالتالي لديه راس مال كبير او على الاقل
مشروع ناجح ممكن اكيد
سنوات العشرينات هي حجر الاساس بالنسبه
لاي شخص فالاستثمار في السنوات العشرينات
سواء استثمار في النفس او الاستثمار في في
عمل مشروع معين هو اهم خطوه لانسان ناجح
كيف فمثلا الناس كثير بتفكر انه الاستثمار
بدايته لازم تكون في عندك اموال كبيره ولا
تكون عندك معلومات معلومات كبيره نفس نفس
الشيء فهو ممكن تفكير غلط نوعا ما مع
التطور تكنولوجي نحن شايفينه مع التواجد
الاي اي مع تواجد عده مؤسسات بتس اعد صار
موضوع كثير مختصر وكثير سواء ماديا او حتى
من نوع الجهد يعني
افضل الاستثمارات او مجالات الاستثمار في
هذا العمر بالنسبه للشباب نظرا بانه ما
بيكون في ماده او مبلغ كبير للاستثمار هل
بنحكي عن الكريبتوكارنسي مثلا ام استثمار
في عقارات حتى وان كان يعني استوديو شيء
صغير جدا ام ماذا ولا بالاسهم
حاليا صارت الاستثمارات متنوعه متعدده فكل
واحد مجاله كل واحد شهفه لوين لوين موديه
فمثلا ممكن يكون استثمار في الكريبتو طرق
من طرق الناجحه لكن حاليا بدها تكون عنده
دراسات مسبقيه الموضوع الاستثمار في
العقارات صارت فيه كتير شركات بتسهل الامر
حتى لو ما عندك فلوس انك تشتري استوديو
كامل ممكن تدخل انت وجماعه في استوديو
تستثمروا فيه مع بعض فصارت فيه تسهيلات
كبيره ماديه
وتسهيلات حتى من نوع من الخبره كذلك
للاشخاص يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يساعد
الشباب
بانه يختصر عمليه تكوين ميزانيه عمليه
دراسه جدوى الى اخره
ويبدا هذا العمل بشيء قليل من المال من
الممكن انه يتطور ولكن يستمع الى نصائح
الخبراء ولا يبتعد يركز على شيء معين اكيد
نحن عنا مثل مثل دائما نقول اهل مكه ادرى
بشعابها فالانسان لازم دائما يستشير اهل
الخبره ما الذي يعمله خلينا نبدا اول شيء
اول شيء هو راس المال
حكينا انه مش لازم يكون عنده راس مال كبير
يقدر حتى يبتدي من صفر فهناك عده مشاريع
ممكن تبتدي من غير راس مال زي الافيليشن
زي مثلا
ما يحتاج في الاول راس مال فقط
هذا الانواع هي انواع ممكن من الشغل اللي
موجود والمشاريع الصغيره الموجوده للشباب
لا تحتاج انواع كبيره اونلاين اكثرها اون
لاين يعني زي دروب شيبنج هو بيعرض
منتوجاتها اعاده توزيع ياخذ البضاعه وانه
مجرد يكون الوسيط
هي نوعا زي الوسيط هناك حاليا كذلك وسيط
سيرفس يعني
ناس من بلد معينه بوصلهم عن طريق ناس
معينه وبياخذ نسبته مثلا هذا ما يحتاج راس
مال لانه مش فاتح شركه قبل ما ننهي لانه
تقريبا انتهى وقتنا اسالك عن موضوع انه
الشباب
بكون ما يكونوا موظفين ما هي المرحله
العمريه المناسبه لانه الواحد يفتح رزقهم
بزنس او يجرب على الاقل اول مره بحيث لا
سمح الله لو ما ظبطت لسه بكون في عنده
منتسع من الوقت انه يرجع لسوق العمل وهل
لازم يبلش اون بيزنس او العمل الخاص له
بعد تخرج مباشره ولا الافضل انه يتوظف على
الاقل يكسب خبره سنه نعم انا انا من من
مدرسه اخذ الخبره في الاول فهو يتوظف تكون
عنده خبره يتعرف على ناس يعرف يكون عنده
مخطط واضح في راسه وكمان ممكن يجمع شويه
فلوس عشان تكون بدايته اسهل اول خطوه
العمل الخاص ايمتى لازم تكون بالعشرين
بعد اخذ الخبره فهو على حسب مجاله ممكن
تكون بدايه العشرينات ممكن في بدايه
الثلاثينات على حسب الخبر على حسب المجال
اللي حابب يدخل فيه للمستثمر يعني نذير
شكرا جزيلا لك نذوح
الباحث ومدير التسويق الاربعيني شو يبدا
ولا ما يبلغ خلاص راحت عليه
شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات